la ville est ce que vous le connaissez
lui attend vous le connaissez lui d'avis
n'ont pas franchement dit la vérité
non non
[Applaudissements]
et ben bella swan et ça va le pays
franchement non mais pourquoi parce que
vous êtes connu bat yeux tout ronds il
était en france
est ce que j'ai fait une soirée dans une
de ces mais il n'est pas le mec est
magique voilà si vous nous regardez le
mec bien de dire à david guetta jeter
dans une boîte en dans une de ces
histoires qu'on voit que tu es pas
reconduit ou pas tu vas j'étais pourtant
me connaissent et valérie bénaïm david
oui voilà estelle denis vous dire non
aux vétérans ça tu peux dire non c'est
la veuve dorée
on connaissait raymond domenech comme
raymond domenech vous connaissez oui bah
c'est son mec ça va
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ils ont fait leurs actions que tout le
monde mais quand on les verrait monde
avec son art au début c'est là le sait
comme dans les bras des bâtiments à ses
novices et le monsieur avec une patte
sur le dette non mais il est sympa il
est super vraiment mais c'est son mari
c'est pas son métier des émissions sur
des buts aussi touche pas à mon sport
tous les jours
mervans ben voila voila je vais vous le
connaissez jean-michel mais bien sûr
mais non mais votre émission je la
regarde
merci donc vous voyez pas que mathieu de
l'ordre revient pas du tout du tout
j'ai toujours la vérité voilà donc bon
il vous connaît pas donc vous avez
quelques années la prochaine fois qu'un
carnet dira oui je le connais voila
voila il était sur nrj 12
ah ben voilà il appelle la même tête que
quand je vais me raymond domenech oui
c'est la scène préférée de david
françois ben non mais c'est pas ça c'est
qu'elle quand j'ai commencé avec eux
qu'ils m'invitaient et merci en tout cas
d'avoir choisi touche pas ou non voilà
moi c'est attends attends si je passe un
truc est un cadeau non parce que tu as
là on parlait de on parlait de des
social media l'attend ce qui est j'ai
commencé j'ai commencé ce match est
alors et david yales commencé alors à
temps yaka van hamme ce qui m'a envoyé
un texto qui m'a dit est ce que david
peu twitté qu'il faut regarder mon
spectacle ce soir sur m6
il va il va le faire à nathan il faut
qu'on le fasse ensemble
d'accord on est anthony missiles on est
en émission c'est sympa mais on est
décontracté mais c'est comme ça alors
vas-y
j'adore ah non mais non mais ça va pas
excuse-moi excellent chien parce que
commencer bien que je suis amateur
ah ben voilà vas-y vas-y mais il faut
parler franc ça oui
allianz
tiens ça là mais j'adore et ça ça fait
intrusion vous rendez compte
je sais que je lance la carrière aux
états unis mais c'est ça
[Musique]